I even made the funnest sticker of the
the big band and put it on the slide
just to be a bit more original because I
give this talking before but it's
revamped so if you watch it it's gonna
have some different stuff I'm Gabriela
Davila Ferrara but I prefer to go by
Gabby because it's easier for everybody
I work at Google cloud and I'm a
developer advocate but that means I was
actually a software engineer for 12
years before before becoming a developer
advocate and if you want to learn more
about me just follow me on Twitter or my
website and it's DM open so you don't
need to follow me at all it's up to you
so my secret now as of this moment is
version 8 0 15 I want to know from the
audience who's here is running my psycho
ain't
raise your hand no one Wow ok that's
gonna be fun 5 7 okay but are you using
the JSON features ok that's ok there's a
lot of cool stuff on my C Corey point
0.15 it's from what I see they've been
releasing you minor versions every three
months but I don't work Oracle so I
don't know how it's gonna be the next
one this one is from February and it has
a following before a brief history and
they can correct me if I'm wrong my
sequel was creating 1995 and it was
created to handle app from 10 to 100
million rows or under 100 megabytes
table so I don't ofor from the myosin
era you know which was way faster they I
know to be at the time now supports
terabyte size data I
have seen really really big databases
running mysql and like not just only the
plain version but the forks that are
around too and for instance I seen the
big ones that I saw had 10 terabytes on
and sometimes I work I have all one of
my great 38 terabytes - through your
service and I'm like yeah we only
support up to day at a time but if
that's how big God supports secret
centers near sequel 2016 so if you don't
know they win revise the sequel
standards every so often every two or
three years but some stuffs just from
2000 to 2003 became available like
window functions and cities comma table
expressions so it's kind of hard balance
so what is awesome now what is exciting
ah well for me
why would be awesome and please take
note it's partial indexes I don't know
if it's it's a which create indexes just
with a condition on the database so that
would be awesome
and instead of select star maybe have an
except that would be nice so those are
my on my wish list please but so this is
one of the new things not the monistic
defaults for table creation that doesn't
mean anything if you don't know what
it's there
it could be deterministic and could be
not what I'm trying to tell you because
oh my god that's finally there it's you
can have functions and expressions on
the create table statement before you
could only have one timestamp for
daytime with current date for instance
or just a constant like number one for
an integer or string for Varsha or sharp
so now they finally are supporting
built-in functions functions are already
on the database
to be the fault called by default and
what does that mean in the end is that
you have more power you have now support
for yo I D my signal now is they tried
to show up as a also document store
that's why I asked about the JSON
features if you're using or not and UUID
is a great part of that because allows
more reliable ID generation than
autoincrement
there was a bug about autoincrement that
took like 10 years to be fixed so that's
one example that would be more suitable
and this is an example of a table having
the UUID so here you see you you ideas
being called you could use before but
not on the create table statement now
you call the UUID and transform to
binary form and save as binary this is
just a recommendation
you could save as a string I don't
recommend it but like save as a binary
form as a primary key also so there is a
demo that I did in here showing up how
that works
so I'm gonna use my blog database and I
don't know if I have the table users for
have I'm gonna drop it so this is the
code that is shown in the slide as I
said before it's a binary it's not no
and so which means you can omit it on
the insert you can only search user name
and it's gonna generate for you like
they do with the auto increment I new
UUID
so I'm gonna create it when I select
it's gonna be empty because I have no
records on it as a setter before you can
omit the use
the primary key in this case because
they are automatically generated for you
and it's gonna insert the UUID but if
you select star from users now you're
gonna see a weird thing because it's in
binary form and you don't want that you
want the UUID so that's when this comes
to life when you convert from binary to
UUID and show the username and this
there it is it looks the same but if you
look in here it's a bit different I'm
going to drop the table again and I'm
gonna show you a use case for an
expression why would you want to do that
not just a new UID but other things
let's say you want to have every
registration of your user on your
website or application you wanted to
have an expiration date and you want to
set up for a year or two years from the
date that the person will register
usually you would keep checking that on
the code like the registration date is
it lesser or equal to the date of today
and doing massive dates is kind of not
nice so there is a way to do that
already saving on the database I'm going
to create the table user I'm gonna copy
this part here so I don't have to type
again and as I said before you can have
created add which was the default as
timestamp not now that's gonna generate
the default current timestamp and now
I'm gonna do it with an expiration date
in our current timestamp but when you
work with expressions in each put it
between parentheses and I'm gonna set up
from the current timestamp plus one
interval of one year it could be any
interval here and I'm gonna create the
table oh I think I need to drop it first
let me see
they created already chopped so when I
insert the data again again I just need
to insert the users and select it you're
gonna see that that case expiration date
is actually a year from the date that
was the creator at there is much for use
cases that's just an example that I
thought you could put a previous column
that's already declared on the
expression and do another expression as
default like times price total spry
price times quantity for instance and
with the definition there so this is one
reason why you would want to have
functions however if you have a custom
function it's not gonna work because
it's only the building functions on
MySQL
another thing that always bugged my mind
was user management it was not easy how
many people here Google every time they
install MySQL how to grant permission to
the root user outside of localhost like
and then that happens to colorful right
so now you could create a DBA role they
have roles so with this Newser
management now you can have reusable
permission and roles so I can't create a
role for DBA and I can use it for myself
I can use it for bath and I can use for
anyone that I want without having to
memorize all that grant that's usually
gigantic and has a password policy so
you can set up how set up the new
password if if you can reuse the
password that you used before then
expiration date on that and the rotation
how long it's valid for so you can have
user management of that so there is a
problem on five seven now if you do a
grant I don't know if it's already
stopping you but gives you a warning
that if you try to create a user using
grant it's gonna say you need to create
use create user not grant to grant
permission because a grant should only
be to grant permissions not create users
with that because it's not creating new
users you don't need to use flush
privileges anymore every time you create
a new user and grant them permissions
and saves you from googling and going to
stack overflow every time so I have an
example here I want a read-only user you
create the role in this case I call
read-only and I'm only applying to the
app database to the read-only role so
anyone that I create now and it gets rid
only can only read from the app database
that's an example of creating a user
that didn't change
you put the user and by the way Gabriela
at percent white card percentage and
Gabriela at local host there are two
different users they're not the same so
you need to pay attention to that and I
just instead of saying grant select
again I just say grant read only to me -
Gabriela at wild card and it's done if
you change anything on the permissions
you don't need to change on the user so
one thing is tied to another making it
easier to do user or user management
there are new stuff under the hood the
default that it's really important if
you're using 570 probably using Latin 1
or utf-8 there's no talk showing how to
hack a database just using utf-8 if
you're using utf-8 please even though
five seven five seven supported use the
T f8 and before as your default not
watching one or just utf-8 because it's
not as secure it's secure there's I saw
the stock is really scary and I was like
whoa I did not know if could that could
do that on the database and one of the
improvements means you can have
mathematical equations now inside the
database and emojis plus snps which in
this case means if I have a weird
language that I just invented with weird
characters I could support it that's
what it means
oh by the way sure set is the
configuration of the car decide where
the how its you're gonna store the beta
and collation is how you're gonna
compare the data so it's important to he
also changed to that thing that's a bit
ugly imminent but why
I'm gonna break it down when they start
I'm studying my secret since 2016 and at
the time the the ISO version for emojis
or stuff like that was 9.0 and but they
are like in version 11 already so they
supported the f8 9.0 that's why this
year 900 and the aici it's because
accent insensitive like my last name has
an accent so you wouldn't matter if you
compare with or without it and case is
sensitive which also doesn't matter but
in each pay attention to if case it's
case insensitive and you're storing a
hashed password you may want to to to
change the collation of that column for
password to be case sensitive because
some hashes have difference between
capital letters or not couple of letters
and there is a weird bug where the sushi
emoji was equal to the beer mochi there
is a blog post on the my Seco server
team which I put it in there it's
because the coalition these both
collisions that they had something was
making them compare one to another and
this person found out just because of
the sushi emerge in the beer moji when
he compared one to another and that
means like if it was comparing that
wrong it would compare other characters
wrong - so that's why coalition is
important so if you go to my secret do
not use general CI or Unicode CI use the
default which it is this one or codes or
case sensitive other the 14 verbals
replication if you use it will binary
login it's an able by default you don't
need to a neighbor anymore there is a
new plugin for education if you try my
Seco it on an older application may have
trouble
because it's using a new plugin for
education that uses shacho for
authentication military default value
for timestamp on columns they are not
know so if you'd have a column that's
not know and use this time SAP it's
going to give you an error if you don't
send that any if you don't set a default
and there is a new dedicate dedicate a
new variable that's for dedicated
servers sometimes you're running on on a
VM and the VM is the only professor zoom
iam is to be a database and you don't
know how to turn that tiny on the
database which I don't so I just said
I'd have to own a let it control for me
the variables they are necessary this is
not an approach what we do in production
but as like a small thing that just
proof of concept you can do it and let
it define for you what is good and what
is not index s made me happy because
although Mexico has most of people use I
know DB and there's other angels like
feather any engines my eyes them taco DB
and memory memory for instance allows
you to create a hash index or if
Ukranian tempura table also create a
hash index but normal tapes are beaten
or motives are v3 and there are be 3
because b3 is on the market sis
1970s it is efficient and they had a
problem because they did not support the
same index as before until 5 7 this is
what it was the syntax would allow you
to add ascending or descending so you
could try now on your 5 6 5 5
installation and that's not gonna give
you any errors it's gonna say that
created the index is descending but
there's a caveat when you look at the
documentation because for future
extensions of my sequel they would
currently they are porst but ignored and
the first time I discovered this I got
so angry because I need a date on this
any order and was not working that I
started like like I know someone that
works there I was like I need the same
exs please put it on and you know and
not because of me of course they didn't
they were because of me but they finally
did it
or mystically and that's how I feel it
like it's freedom finally you could say
it's a b-tree you could reverse it and
it could get the same result but on my
Saku didn't work like that before
so I'm gonna leave you for with me with
wait for him a little bit more just easy
so that's the syntax now it's the same
syntax you know it's no longer ignore
and it's no longer forcibly created as I
say me because you would say that is
descending but would create as assigning
which it's not cool so actually works
now the cool thing about that it's even
though you're not using the index on a
descending manner like I did it in here
it's gonna use the index anyway it's got
it's gonna know that's they already has
I indexing username that's this any it's
gonna say okay I'm gonna get up from the
other part of it and transverse it from
there so that's one one thing that made
performance improvements on a lot of
databases so so if you use a lot of the
sanema access this descending queries
maybe just a forgetting to my secrets
are going to gain all the performance
because of that creating that kind of
indexing so another one are invisible in
taxes and that one I was surprised
because I never heard of this concept
before I have a table users it's kind of
just user name and created and updated
at and I do have a I forgot to put any
here but I do have
in acts on username because I'm gonna
search by username so with invisible in
taxes it's not used by the optimizer so
if you put an index as invisible the
optimizer did not run on the query so
you think why the hell would I do that
if it's not gonna be used what I'm going
to put an invisible well there's a lot
of reasons because every index is
visible by default and to create an
invisible one you just put it as
invisible and one of the reasons is to
drop by index or create an index it's a
really costly operation it takes a while
and depends on the size of your table I
had an eight-course machine with 52
gigabytes of RAM and on a table with 50
million records it took two minutes to
create an index that's fast but not
everybody can afford to have a machine
like that so the thing is sometimes you
create too much in taxes and the one
index starts to get away in the way of
another so if you can just disable it
put it's invisible you can debug better
your query so it's more for the bug
purposes only as invisible even if you
create as invisible doesn't mean it's
not updated it continues being updated
but it won't it's not used by the query
planner you can toggle the visibility so
if you create as invisible or visible
and want to change it you just do an
outer table auto index and shrink
visible or visible that's just that
that's an example of the query cost so
I'm looking for a username called fake
fancy it's just it's all generated user
names because of GDP or so I just use
added adjectives to the user names and
with the visible index the cost was zero
and
and only one road so it found one row on
invisible access just turning it as
invisible it did a full table scan on
five million rows of five million users
that I had just toggling on and off this
is a demonstration because the cool
thing about that it's because it is fast
to do it so first I'm gonna show you my
order by username it found me and that's
not the right database sorry about it
and if you look here
that's all those results and it does use
the index and if I change to the sending
because I created as a setting using the
X condition the same index that I
created before but backward index scan
so it still uses it now that right now
the index is visible if I toggle the
visibility to invisible it's gonna be a
fast operation already changed and when
I do the explain of the same query it
uses type all fun and rows here it's
five million just to be doing you like
I'm not going to run it because it's
gonna take forever but that's just the
explained if we're not used to it so
target toggling on and off helps you
debug the the the queries and my of
course is that over simplistic example
but if you have too many indexes you may
want to use that instead of dropping
your index and creating indexes again
and you saw how fast was and it was fast
because they my secret before had two
algorithms to run outer tables and that
kind of stuff and one was in place and
the other one was copy you know probably
copy very well because every time you
added a column would copy the whole
table again rename it and drop the old
table now they have instant algorithm
with instance you can add columns
without without doing any place or
cooperation which means you can add
instantaneously a column to the table
without having to wait that long
there's there's limitations you need to
be appending a column to a table what
that means you do not use like I'm gonna
create the I don't know status and add
after username if I do add after put
after username it's gonna have to wish
shift the table so it's gonna be a copy
operation so it's not gonna be
spontaneous Li but if you're just re on
the end just a penny and you don't care
about the order about the the columns
it's got a miscellaneous and must not
have a default value on the new column
it can be not no but it cannot have a
default value because again then what I
have to copy the table all over again
he naming table modifying columns ritual
columns if before on five seven they
were in place operation which is still
fast but now they're innocent and if you
change the default on a column it should
be also instant because of our feature
called data dictionary that's on MySQL
eight it's it it changed the
architecture of how things work under
the hood and now a lot of the changes
that you do you do to a metadata you
don't do it to the table to the file
itself it's just a metadata change which
you lead sometimes to interesting bugs
like on my sequel 8 0 13
they found a bug if you rename the table
and had a foreign keys you would lose
consistency the foreign keys would not
work
just because you rename the table so
there's still get either so keep up to
date always in fear database of your
minimal versions and this is an example
I'm adding a column total to orders it's
a decimal column and I'm forcing the
algorithm to be instant
it took 0.26 seconds which is really
fast for table that has 50 million
records
which took 7.8 seconds to count so was
faster to add a column and then took out
how many rows I have on that table
but with all as you see I did put not
know but I did not put a default value
so you can have not know on there both
sugars had a problem as far as I know if
it needed to be knowable to be able to
be instantly added in my secret can do
if not know which is which is nice now I
want to stop for a minute because we're
using usually what we call all ltp
databases which my sequin posters are
all l TP stands for online transaction
I forgot the P okay I'll enter lines
transactions and the app which is for
analytical queries it's online
analytical I forgot to pee again
my security features that OLAP database
for instance like bigquery has because
it's columnar into OLTP database which
means you could do analytical queries
inside my sequel now without having to
create a ETL send it to whatever
database you do columnar database you'd
want a little analytics on but you
should not abuse it that's why I said
stop because it's not performance is not
as good as it would be for normal crude
Curt queries so the first one it's
window functions window functions are
they are able to analyze the rows of a
given result set if you use a window
function it does not change what is on
the results
it's gonna look on the result and give
you insight what on what you have it's
like when you're going
it's like menu if your camera phone
you're here see me speak and you put
your camera to take a picture me and you
have a frame and I'm the result set this
room is the result side but you can move
the frame and see details of it that's
the same idea or you just can pick over
it as we say it pick over the result set
of a window so you can use to enumerate
rose-like use roll number count how many
rows you have aggregated sums let's say
ecommerce you have a court and the user
let's say bought a chair and bought a
table or and you want to calculate how
much is expanding not a total of the
bill but like for each item how much I'm
accumulating for each turns for each
item there on go adding it to the court
you can do that with some rank you rank
the results based on any parameter that
you have or look that's cool in my
opinion on the row before or after the
row you are which is leading like and I
have an example for you
I have an order stable and it's data
generator so the updated add could be
different from the Creator add and
before after so I'm sorry for that but
I'm gonna create this disable and this
is the result that I get it I want to
look at creator at for this user this 6
5 4 3 2 1 user and I want to know when
it was the previous order that the user
had if we're doing PHP you have an array
a result set and you can look at the
next item of the array or the professor
wonder array and give you the result but
your can have also this on the sequel
query so lag means I'm getting the row
before so I'm getting from created at
which is the the item that I'm
interested on over create it at again
the same idea that were interested on on
the ascending order so because I want to
order before and then the lead which it
is the order that come after so I'm
saying here give me the created add
column at the row before me and created
at column and the row after me it's
gonna look like this here is no because
before the first order there's no other
first order so it's gonna be no so the
right one for the second line is
actually the next order for the first
one so it's the lead however it's it's
it's the lead however for the third line
is the lag it's a bit complicated when
you see a first but like you could see
for instance you can do an elite
analytics on this and see oh how much
time does it take for a user to do order
again on my website and you do one - an
order and you have the interval in days
or seconds or years whatever so that's
one use case for that so previous order
in X order break down the function
itself lag the column that you're
working on how many rows before after
the first one was proceeding and the
window
so we're developers we hate repetition
we like dry and this I mean I love
writing sequel and but I hate copying
pasting and I try for me this is them
there's a lot of discussion about this
lately well like it's visual that this
this thing for me but there's one thing
that helps you which it is named in the
windows so it's the same you declare a
window which are called me dates and I
said what that window is and then when I
use lag lead I said that I'm using over
dates that way if I change my window I
don't have to change my select again and
it can have multiple windows per query
also I have a demonstration of that
so this is the crane that we have on the
on the slide and was pretty fast when we
saw there's 50 million orders there and
this is my problem given three users get
me the top five orders of each user ID
so a lot of people would disavow is what
I do is is this let's first rank it
let's rank what are the top orders of
these users so I'm gonna be placing here
and gonna copy because it's gonna be
faster that way I'm gonna remove the lag
and the lead those are the users I put
it in here already that I'm interested
on so if I do this wait a moment
users
those are all the orders for those users
that are on my system so I limit for ten
now let me remove the limit 29 so I want
on the five per per user so I should
have 15 right so let's rank it I'm gonna
rank and when I rank I need to say over
what
that's my window so I'm gonna rank over
user ID partition by it's like a group
by but it's a bit different partition by
user ID and order by total the signing
and it's gonna give me the ranked result
for everything let me put in here
yes
and to make it easier I'm gonna remove
the credit at the order ID so for this
user - - - - this is the the order with
most expensive so you can see the price
and the second one more expensive and
the third one more expensive and so on
and so on but I only want this top free
how you do that
I feel more writing on PHP you just get
it up 3 of all the results
that's where common table expressions
come in because remember window
functions do not change the result set I
cannot change this result but I can
build on top of it so I'm gonna build on
top of this I'm gonna say this is my
rank orders and it's defined as this
query that we just created and I'm gonna
filter it I just need to filter now I
need to filter from ranked orders where
the rank order is last or equal to 5 I
wanted so it should have 15 results and
yes you can see 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 1 2
3 4 5 that's the power of window
functions inside the common table
expression which I'm going to explain
right now how it works
the sum you could say I want to know how
much accumulated spent the user had so
if you do a sum on total over
[Music]
it's gonna give you the total order
how much dye user is spent on everything
that's for this user wait / partition by
user ID
so each user spend that amount of money
on all the orders but you can have a
aggregated one if you order by 90
so you see made a moan
so it's it's ugly but like it's how it
looks like if you say partition by user
ID because you're getting for that user
the cumulative spanning rows unbowed
proceeding the rules there are before so
the first row I spent total of
twenty-two hundred something and the
other one two hundred something so the
sum of those two rows of 409 and then
the sum of the three rows is 532
something and so on so on so you could
actually then create another table
expression to see the difference of
spanning between one thing and another
so that's why we call it analytical
queries I showed you a common table
expression but I didn't explain to you
what it is it's similar to create
temporary table but you don't need to
create privilege you just need to have a
Select privilege to use it you can
reference other cities if those already
define I created a city and I could use
it on another city and you know join
them together and I have a beautiful
query with all the analytics that I want
it can be recursive too and it's easier
to read then a sub query it is would be
a sub query of five then a query and
then the sub query to get the results
that you want I'm going to show you a
bit of worker subsidies because they are
useful for you hierarchical data who
here uses WordPress who here knows what
you have categories and there are
subcategories and then there's sub sub
categories which are hierarchical data
there probably I didn't look at the code
or crying that high structure that
traversal
in the PHP code not in the database but
you can do that on the database instead
of doing that on your code so base coid
comes first it's all recursion starts
with a simple case then a second query
comes after a Union statement and the
stop condition should be on the
recursive call so because there is a
problem of that or how much recursion
you can do and by the faults I think
it's 500 recursions I increase for this
demo but you should put a where to know
where what is your breaking point for
that recursion so I have my categories
on my blog and I'm I have animal and
plants as main categories and although
all the other ones are child children
for other categories that's an example
of hierarchical data but I want to
traverse that tree that's what I said
that I was once tried to do okay why is
mine okay
I'm not gonna look at that so I'm gonna
start here it's like the other one you
start with it with but you say recursive
you give it a name I'm gonna call it a
tree but I don't think it's a tree but
I'll call it call it a tree and then
what are the fields of that that table
that I'm creating because I'm creating a
table here so it's gonna be that level
name the path because I want to know the
path of the hierarchical data and the
node ID and then you need to do the
definition again basic case first
so the basic case is going to be that
level equal to one I'm gonna call root
as my first name but Mitsuko has a
problem of that you cannot use text as a
recursive field or wash or only Shore so
if I recognize it is a Shore and it's
4/4 and if I have like the word animal
which is higher than four so would give
me an error so I need to cast this as a
washer that's bigger sure that's bigger
which I'm gonna do two five five in here
and the same thing for the path because
the path could get big and I'm gonna use
the maximum that I can in here which is
this number of negative numbers and what
is my first note it's zero because point
and animal the parent ID it was zero so
that's my first use case if I do select
star from tree I should get one result
only for now now comes the recursion you
doing Union all
and then I select I have my glue in here
because sometimes I forget and you're
gonna sell X I'm gonna leave it blank
for now from tree and from categories
I'm sorry and inner join on three and
I'll explain later
so from the first one is my duct level
for each recursion I'm gonna increase
the depth level in one so it's that
level plus one the name is gonna be the
same it I want to show the name of the
category so it's gonna be categories dot
name now I want to show the path I'm
gonna use a function that my escrow has
which is concat word separator I don't
know if you know it which means
concatenate the string and add this
character to it to split it on the path
because I want to keep the path so on
tree path with the name that I just got
which is categories dot name and in the
end I want to know the note ID which it
is categories ID however my inner join
is incomplete here I'm gonna join the
tree on what on the tree the node ID its
sequel to the categories for category ID
and that should work technically
speaking I hope let me organize it okay
okay Oh wrong database what and it did
work but it's hard to read a bit I'm
gonna do an improvement here order by
path to be easier to see the path and in
the end you have the Traverse tree of
all the categories of a table I didn't
need to put a stopping condition because
I only have like 11 so I didn't reach
maximal dots but you should have
something like where that's level lasso
equals 5 for instance and then it's
going to give you the same result that's
a use case for recursive city so instead
of reusing your script to go querying
all the time together the stuff in it
you can use that to be able to get it so
that's gonna be on offshore this line
this is the base case as I said before
and this is the query that I wrote same
same query and now sub queries I don't
like sub queries but they are useful
sometimes who here did this everybody
no come on everybody did this at least
once you never put a sub query inside of
select never okay I'll pretend that I
believe you so I'm now I'm having to
sell cars here and there are the same
sub queries I'm just getting the IDE and
the total from the table orders should
be an easier way to do that instead of
getting it this way there is its
collateral and it's new oh I see Kuwait
whatever it's like a for each it means
for each row on this result please do
this query and the several returning
only one column which you only have
access on the Select you can look to
return how many columns you want because
it's creating a lateral table to your
users that's why it's collateral and you
see here I call it total orders and I
use as ID and total here to be able to
show it
performance-wise the other ones better
for now
depends on how many columns you're
bringing but on variability on my
opinion this is better to read then the
other one is
and I'm just gonna show it's not a job
it's a lateral joint the problem is you
my query I'm gonna show you here the use
cases I want the biggest order of the
user on a joint you would have no
control over that you could use a group
by to get the maximum order you're right
but then I couldn't get the same ID on
the same row because when you use an
aggregator the only going to use that
column it doesn't guarantee the column
that's next to it you would have to do
twice so that's one example that's the
same query and what I want to show you
it's how they behave
so this I'm gonna pin this result
because I want to compare to the one
using tomorrow which it is this one it's
not the same result and there's a reason
why when you do the sub-query here this
one is with the sub-query you're getting
all the users and then looking for
orders that the user has if it doesn't
have in your order is gonna return no
which makes sense but the lateral
guarantees that you're not gonna have a
user that doesn't have orders it's like
I in their joint that's why it's called
lateral join in this case